I had no one else to compare myself to
like I wasn't comparing myself to any
other 22 or 23 year old out there in
fact I thought I was doing pretty good
because I was like Hey I've come out of
University and I've got a job whereas
now you got people who were like 16 20
21 who were just making a killing and I
think because they're so out there on
social media and they have gained quite
a lot of following because of the
success they've had I think a lot of
guys maybe that age or even a little bit
older they're like hang on I was this
guy managed to make so much money and so
successful I am literally doing nothing
with my life
Michael first welcome to the show hello
Chris good to see you again thank you
for letting me use your house to record
this in what do you think I know you're
a bit of a connoisseur of uh
setups when it comes to podcasting what
do you think of this one I think it's
really nice uh loving whatever that is
some old school old and worldy Telescope
type like I think that's very nice very
well done I'm impressed you've entered
the the dark and dingy world of
podcasting yeah how are you finding it
I'm finding it good actually it's
probably been one of the things which I
have learned the most out of like what
it's taught me so far from just having
conversations with people doing research
about people and being able to hold a
conversation it's it's been very
interesting well you've done YouTube for
a very long time how long have you been
on YouTube now first video went up 2016.
but I guess that's still quite a long
time yeah it was I went hardcore in
2017. that's when it kind of took off so
what
Looking Back Now and obviously having
this Big Arc of content creation for the
last coming up on a decade being on a
platform which is getting ever more
successful ever more popular more and
more people joining more and more people
being competitive what have been the
principles that have managed to get you
to not only a stage that you've got a
sizable platform
but also have managed to help you avoid
being dragged into the muck and the mire
and the politics and the backbiting the
reaction videos and the call outs and
all that sort of stuff you've done a
very good job of avoiding that I think
I've never really been massively
opinionated on anything I'm quite
neutral and I would keep like say for
example a lot of my content training
related it would just be about the
training I would never call anyone out
or say anyone else's name it would just
be
what I believe you need to do when it
comes to training building muscle losing
body fat same thing with our transition
to Vlogs and lifestyle it was mainly
just either about me and what I was up
to or the place that I'm going to not
about the people is that a
purpose-built strategy to avoid getting
yourself into politics or is that just I
think so I think I generally just don't
like drama
I would like to avoid it if possible why
because it's just
don't like it stress stress and I think
um I think his Petty once like the drama
starts it's like backwards forwards
backwards forwards it never really ends
and then sometimes can get a little bit
like
some people might say something they
regret and I didn't want to do something
or make a video while I think oh that
was a bit super and childish yeah what
about the principles what else have you
done you know looking back on the the
come up to get from where you were to
where you are now what just be myself
I think you see a lot of Trends over
time and people tend to try and like hop
onto Trends or do what other people are
doing who are really popular but I just
stuck to doing what I do and I feel
comfortable doing and I feel like that
has worked massively for me and the
problem that people come up against I
think is first off if you're playing a
role like if you're trying to be someone
else or your version like YouTube mic or
YouTube whatever
you get found out pretty quickly because
people are always going to look for
hypocrisy or discontinuity between who
you say you are and who you actually end
up being yeah and the other side I I
think that we're both pretty aligned on
is
if you're not careful you get known for
the drama and nothing else yeah you
don't actually get known for your work
or your takes or your expertise or your
insights or anything like that what you
get known for is like okay when's the
next reaction video back and forth
incoming and that's like a really bad
situation to be yeah like the prime
example of that in the fitness industry
would be Greg Doucet
and fair play he's doing his thing
that's obviously his business model and
it's working he's getting the views but
like you said that's that's kind of what
he's known for and that's not something
I would ever I wouldn't want to be known
for the guy that has made
uh platform or generated a big following
just from doing reaction videos for the
people
would you watch Greg's content if it
wasn't sometimes like I do watch some
videos yeah yeah because he might just
do like a a reaction or it's almost like
a a news channel now when someone in the
fitness area has done something or
something's happening or usually it's
negativity because the negativity brings
in the views and there's been a few
times I'm like oh that looks like some
juicy gossip yeah you do need someone to
go out and find out what's going on I
suppose it very much is kind of like a
news feed for the fitness industry I
suppose
Derek does it but Derek has a
I guess he hasn't done it as much
recently I guess he's on to bigger
things now but in the past he used to do
that he grinds he I mean dude I've got
to watch because obviously my housemate
was a big part of Derek's liver King
video so Zach calendar is a guy that I
live with he did the charlatans Playbook
section of that video and his editor
Alex was the guy that actually put the
whole thing together and I watched them
work on this thing for [__] age he
did a very good job of Ages and ages man
and I'm watching it happen and unfold
behind the scenes and I I wouldn't have
surprised me if Derek would have asked
me to sign an NDA I didn't need to
because I'm not going to tell anyone
about it or spoil it but they worked so
[__] hard on that thing
um and yeah I do think that Derek's a
particularly good example of someone
that just decides okay here's my
expertise I'm gonna go at this thing the
problem is that there is a a little bit
of fall off he's inevitably going to get
himself embroiled in some of those
politics yeah right because of the type
of content that he's doing obviously one
of the things one of the things that
Eric did recently him and Matt does
Fitness yeah because last time that we
spoke was about two and a half years ago
a couple of miles in that direction I
think and we were talking then and all
of the like Izzy natural accusations
that have followed you since we were in
uni basically like 15 years ago
and I think that one of the concerns
that you'd had then was well
no matter what test you do there is
always going to be somebody that says
it's insufficient it's not enough it's
blah blah blah and I think Matt had that
problem too Matt went to Derek and said
design me the most rigorous randomized
testing protocol in the world is that
something that yes
I've emailed Derek and I've WhatsApp
Derek two months ago right no reply
you're kidding me you're kidding I'll
show you after this because I spoke to
obviously I've seen this all happening
I've been watching the videos I speak to
Matt he's like one of my best friends
and
um
Matt was telling me because I asked for
his number Matt was saying
uh just be aware it's a massive ball
like
on both ends because he has to be
available to do all these random tests
he's got to pay for it but then Derek
has to do so much organization
you know he's getting things set up in a
country which he doesn't live in and the
whole process he can't just do all these
random tests in a week or two weeks it
has to be over exactly five month period
yeah so
um he got on that first did everything
he could have possibly done and proved
that he's not taking anything so I saw
the announcement of Matt's thing I never
actually saw the results did he get yeah
leaner and stronger and well the results
I think because it was all messed up
because he tore his Achilles
like before the testing started playing
football
so he's I don't know what he's trying to
prove that he could still maintain his
lifts or something so I think he was
able to bring it back but he was getting
tested throughout and there was no funky
stuff happening okay but it was
interesting because he's making these
videos and proving that it's natural and
then there's still people who are like
no I don't believe you they're not happy
so why did you if that's the case why
would you message Derek if Matt's gone
through the most rigorous testing
protocol available to man and that's
still not sufficient for some people
because I think there's literally
nothing more you can do
and if anybody is going to oversee any
kind of testing I would want Derek to do
it because I'd pick up the phone I know
I'll ring him I'll ring him once we're
finished up I was texting him this
morning I've got the email and WhatsApp
but I'm not gonna pester him to because
I imagine how busy he is to give him his
due that man is drowning in emails 24 7.
yeah there was a period of
I'll ask him if I can put this into the
podcast I'm sure he won't have a problem
with it but we can cut it if need to be
uh after he released the liver King
video which was you know this big
Crescendo and then he does Rogan then he
does me then he does Zach uh what's that
then he does uh like a comedy podcast
and then maybe just one more and he was
like dude I'm I have six months of
unanswered emails to deal with because
all he'd been doing was grinding
creating content then build up to this
kind of big Crescendo maximum thing and
then all he's like what's he released
like three videos maybe since
November December time because he's
super busy this is one of the things
that I don't know people don't
really see the
pain that goes into creating content
like that or even for you it's so
effortful to make a [__] Vlog yeah
the vlog's along dude it is so painful
and
it looks like a a beautiful life the
number one uh desired job amongst
American children is influencer yeah now
and I would imagine that you know
YouTuber would probably get folded into
that
there are some amazing parts of the job
but there are some bits that absolutely
suck if you're sat with your editor the
night before it needs to be uploaded
looking at the edit unhappy with
something giving him amends on frame dot
IO or whatever it is that you're using
yeah
it's not that much fun and I think that
what you're seeing with Derek is you
know the fall off on you but it's the
same with me I used to have this really
strict schedule where I would have to
post a certain time on a certain day and
I would literally be pulling my hair out
just to make sure that everything was
perfect everything was filmed and when I
wasn't you know maybe two hours were
left before the upload and it wasn't
ready I would be so stressed out and
then I just thought it's not even worth
it I'll just remove the schedule
it's posted when it's ready yeah post it
a day later two days later what do you
think this is an interesting thing
especially given that you've been in the
YouTube scene for a very long time since
before I think before Derek was on
YouTube although he has been on for a
long time talking about non-fitness
content
do you think that he has been
one of the bigger biggest influences in
kind of shaping Fitness YouTube over the
last few years what do you think is sort
of I think so in terms of Education
definitely because he's he's like a
freaking encyclopedia he knows so much
so he's definitely
he's definitely had a positive impact
I don't know anyone else who's I think
there's a few other people now who are
pretty clued up when it comes to Jeff
nepard maybe yes he puts a hell of a lot
of work into his videos yeah there's
another guy he puts the I've got his
name he puts all these um
like uh uh bands on his muscles okay so
it can pick up the twitching of the
fibers and he does all these exercises
oh and there's a Ryan Ryan something
okay what and he and that will determine
how much yeah so muscle activation yeah
muscle activation doing different
exercises I've never seen it before and
I watched a few of his videos and he's
he's very uh charismatic mathematic and
staining that's cool yeah I so
what would you the trend when you
started YouTube uh you know what I I
think I was I was lucky because I was
early yes I would agree you know that
Rob lips it like Harrison twins kind of
era ish I think was a
you know it was a golden era for like
bro content Vlogs lifestyle lifting
to me now and I'm outside of that
uh whatever like cohort of delivery on
YouTube in any case
but to me it it really feels like the
um
evidence-based you know sort of more
scientific approach to education I'm
sure that there still are big lifestyle
channels out there but like I don't see
your Jeff's sides of the world your
David laids of the world like they don't
that that style seems to have dropped
away and even your stuff seems to be
leaning increasingly towards education
even outside of Fitness is that but I
feel like that is what YouTube is
becoming it's becoming more of a
platform for education
like you said there is there there is
always going to be room for those uh
vloggers and lifestyle
people like Jesse James he's smashing it
at the moment yeah there's only very few
people who can do that
and
maybe this I feel like it's it's one of
those things where people have seen
everything true it's hard to reinvent
unique yeah so Zach my housemate was at
the Arnold Classic a couple of weeks ago
and uh Jesse James was there with an
army of security guys I don't he didn't
know what he was dressed up as he was
dressed up as something he had a big
suit on he had a big beard on maybe he
was being Chris bomb steady and I don't
know he's like he's being something and
uh Zach said watching it from the
outside is [__] insane yeah like
because it's just this reality
Distortion field moving through uh a
crowd he is he's
one of the best I've seen he came to
Dubai yes yeah you featured in a video I
remember yeah yeah and I just watched
him work and I was like wow like
everything he's got he thoroughly
deserves however
he's not going to be able to keep that
up why because he'll burn out
he's he's young I think he's like 23-24
so we know when he's made of rubber and
Magic you've got that do you remember
being 23 or 24 yeah it was [__] full
of energy
that's what I'm noticing now I'm like
I'm gonna be 33 this year and I'm
noticing like
and the worst thing is like homozy said
it it's like this is the most energetic
you are going to be it's down here
yeah well Jesse's Jessie's a very
interesting one I think because it's the
skit style of video
without the cringe and the cheese the
one there was one that he did with
Ronnie Coleman and Jay Cutler that I to
me pushed the limit on the upper bound I
was like if this goes much more it's
going to be a little bit like oh uh but
the one that you did where he pretended
to be Chris Bumstead for the people that
don't know who were talking about Jesse
James Fitness YouTuber
um very charismatic guy young dude from
America and he does two and a half
million Subs nothing and he hasn't been
going that long no and he's absolutely
flying but that's that's the you know
it's evident that he's got I don't know
whether he's following he is well first
of all he is a big ball of energy yep
insane amount of energy I think very
extroverted yep he has absolutely no
fear going up to people which was very
interesting to watch as well and he's
just he's just a hard worker always
working
like Hotel there's always a million
things going on in his head you'd be
concerned about his ability to keep up
that work right
yeah
I don't because it like it just gets to
a point I think with unless you really
really love something most of the time
you're kind of like oh yeah
this is getting a bit repetitive now
like it's not necessarily sustainable is
his work rate effortful I haven't Zack
said it looks like a massive reality
Distortion field moving through a an
expo but it's just it's like flying
around constantly planning constantly
just being in front of the camera like I
couldn't only imagine how many
how much actually doesn't even get put
into the video like you only see the
best of the best you don't see like all
the uh the outtakes well that's another
reason why the Vlog format is just so
impractical right you know you want to
film a vlog about your I remember you
you did uh some stuff about you got a
nice new car and you wanted like to let
people know about the car that you've
got it took like two days yeah yeah it's
a 16 minute [__] videos here we have
to drive all the way to the desert which
is like an hour away then we had to
drive up and down this track with
another car we're filming so we're
probably filming that little 20-second
edit for like an hour yep and then
that's a podcast you would have had a
podcast I don't know about driving
somewhere else just to do like a talking
part which I kept [__] up and then I
was just like wow this is two or three
days work yeah and now I'm noticing it's
like it's not practical I do like the
Vlogs and I still think it's a big part
of my channel
but I think now I only want to make a
vlog if something really cool is
happening either I'm meeting up with
someone very interesting or I'm going
somewhere really cool the travel Vlogs
are wicked because it's like documenting
myself going on holiday yeah and then
I'm also sharing the place
with people
I did a the reason I'm here in Dubai is
because I just did a debate in Qatar so
uh is masculinity under attack and um
it's the first time that I've done
anything remotely close to TV uh for
quite a long time you know I got
familiar with it with the dating stuff
take me out love Island and then other
bits of produced documentaries but
especially after having spent so much
time doing this
where if you forget you forgot the guy's
name that puts the thing around his arm
if that happens on TV that's a cut right
let's research it shout it out uh and
then we'll run it again from the top can
you say I could just run that again for
us please it's like whereas it's weird
there's no flows no no no not at all no
of course not because they they've got
45 minutes they've got ad breaks to go
in between all the rest of the stuff
either trying to sell it to Netflix or
they're trying to do whatever and the
thing that we did was like incredibly
well produced massive team to 100 150
people on site to do this thing
unbelievable production but even with
that you know there's there's things
that the host that was mediating the
debate needs to do and for me it just
feels uh experientially so much more
like stop starting you know we the guy
that I was debating me and him weren't
supposed to speak to each other before
like when we were backstage whereas if
even if you were sitting down to have a
conversation with someone that you
disagreed with you'd welcome that door
give them a glass of water say oh okay
blah blah three two one welcome to the
show and you just crack on
um that's why I don't like TV anymore it
seems so fake and staged it doesn't seem
real it's so trite to say like every you
know Rogan and all of those guys have
been going going on about it for ages
but look at what Jesse James does right
his content
is heavily staged but it's done in a way
that almost draws you in yeah right it's
quite likable it's quite enjoyable and
yeah I'm just fascinated
um about what's happened with especially
like the vlogging world I think the rise
of podcast has trickled down you know
you being able to do q and A's you've
been able to do direct to camera things
but if someone was starting up a channel
now we were talking about this earlier
on what advice would you say someone's
listening and they go I fancy making a
YouTube channel I'm prepared to sell my
soul to the devil I have absolutely I'll
go as low as I need to I'll play any
role that I need to
how would you from first principles just
say this is how to get to a million Subs
as quickly as possible if you're
prepared to sell your soul yeah if you
wanted to with the absolute minimal work
required you can just pick up other
people's content viral content and just
react to it and have some sort of
animated reaction which will provide
people some form of entertainment and
you're just kind of
piggybacking off other people's amazing
work which is kind of like quite
questionable but if you want to grow
very quickly
that's one way to do it another way it
depends how
how knowledgeable you are as a person
like if you have a not a lot of
knowledge to spread and you're very good
at communicating and can present
yourself well all you have to do is just
sit down and talk
make it you know a little bit
entertaining have an editor put some
cool edits on it and then you can just
bang out videos non-stop that makes it
sound very easy
yeah I guess it's a little bit harder
than that but it is in a way it's I'm
trying to work out you know given the
fact that I think that you're not far
off I don't disagree
uh I'm just trying to work out where it
is that people get stuck
they don't have a skill set they don't
have any value to offer I think oh so
they don't have any expertise that they
can actually talk on yeah well I mean I
was having a discussion with a friend
about this today about
um
Aubrey Marcus CEO of on it founder of on
it now sold it um told me this thing a
few years ago he said that you don't
serve people from your cup you serve
them from the source that overflows
around your cup and he's saying it in
classic Austin psychedelic fashion right
but what he actually means is sort your
[__] first
you need to make sure that you are
sufficiently capable to do the you thing
before you then try and proselytize to
the world about how they should be doing
it or how you did it and they can do it
how you did it and stuff which is why I
think if you look at almost all of the
podcasts that are doing very well you
know you're talking like Rogan 50s
huberman 40s like Tim Dillon 30s
crystallia late 30s 40s like all of
these you know whether it's comedy
whether it's whatever pick pick your big
name podcast Tim Ferriss 40s like these
guys are older
well hang on if you go to other social
media they're not the ones that crush on
Instagram or Tick Tock or whatever
unless it's repurposing content from a
different platform
and I think that the reason for that is
and it's a very good change we can like
complain about and I do I'm like rail
against Tech talk in short form and it's
killing people's brains and blah blah
but certainly one of the good things is
that
people who have genuine expertise and
who don't have been thrown into harsh
light by long-form conversations yeah
because if it's a good thing sit someone
down for an hour and a half and you go
oh there's nothing there there's
absolutely nothing there there's nowhere
to hide in these conversations yeah and
I think
the older you get the wiser you are and
the more life experience you have it's
quite hard for you to sit there and
listen to a 22 year old tell you how you
should live your life particularly if
you're like over 30 even though they
might actually know how to live life
better than you do guys a lot of guys
are just W2 stuff and they'll be like
nah I'd rather listen to someone who's
the same age as me or a little bit older
and it's one of the reasons why I held
off from this podcast for books I
remember when we did ours I was like man
like that was amazing like I think I
want to do my own and then I was like
nah not yet
haven't got the expertise which is crazy
right for people to look at I think I
just needed I needed two more years of
living life and I certainly did that
what's your views on why men are feeling
sort of quite lost at the moment because
me and you went to UNI at basically the
same time I think we're one or two years
age difference we did the same course at
Newcastle we trained at the center for
sporting Excellence right the CSE
together which would have been your
first major like consistent gym yeah
that's what I would do my bro Split For
the First Time damn right
um so we would have been walking through
Richardson Road horse of residence in
where did you live where were you in
first castle eases wait you Posh twice
no yeah but this is the thing I didn't
know I didn't I don't know why I picked
it but I picked it and then I realized I
was like the only northerner correct
yeah the people that don't know
Newcastle University Northeast of the UK
should have been a Richardson Road
should have been in Ricky Road
um I was in Saint Mary's and Fannin
because I put it as my insurance and
they make you pay uh you were in with
all of the Posh boys my point being when
we went to University when we were the
age of a lot of the guys that are
seeking advice online at the moment
that was there was nothing online but I
don't think that there was a sense of
being lost despite the fact that there
was less information out there I don't
think that
and and that's not to say that me and
you tumbled into some like perfect slick
archetype of being of finding our place
within University or whatever I think
both of us in like like certain ways
we're a little bit disjointed and took
time to find our feet yeah
what do you think's changed why is it
that guys are I think it's maybe the
comparison aspect of it because I
definitely didn't have a clue what I was
doing and I think
it was only until I was 23 yeah 23 when
I became a personal trainer and I was
like okay so this is probably a step in
the right direction before that I was
working as a manager and Hollister work
the club club promoter for a bit doing
all sorts but I never felt lost I was
just like
okay well yeah I'll just I'll just do
this but I had no one else to compare
myself to like I wasn't comparing myself
to any other 22 or 23 year old out there
in fact I thought I was doing pretty
good because I was like Hey I've come
out of University and I've got a job
whereas now you got people who are like
16.
20 21 22 who were just making a killing
and I think because they're so out there
on social media
and they have gained quite a lot of
following because of the success they've
had I think a lot of guys maybe that age
or even a little bit older they're like
hang on how's this guy managed to make
so much money and so successful and I am
literally
doing nothing with my life comparatively
even if you are on a graduate scheme at
Hollister
I think that's one thing and then maybe
the value of a degree is must have gone
downhill now I don't think
people are thinking oh should I go to
university anymore is it worth it like
do I need to go do I not need to go like
what should I spend my time learning
I think it can be quite confusing out
there all of my richest friends don't
use their degrees Yeah I don't use my
degree you don't George the guy that I
was at at his house before unbelievably
successful marketing business did
philosophy at Uni can't remember any of
it
like I I think that all of that's very
correct is a quote that says comparison
is the thief of joy and
maybe that maybe that contributes to a
big part of it the fact that
just your ability to see
naught Point not not one percent success
absolute outliers crushing at a younger
age than you
uh so I went to the UFC's power slap
event in Vegas last Saturday which was
[__] wild and I saw Aiden Ross one of
the biggest streamers in the world I saw
all of the milk boys Kyle uh Mike from
uh impulsive hospital was there Dan
Bilzerian was there like just bing bing
like tick pick your steeple do it like
everybody right all of the the biggest
guys that would have been around that
that sort of community
and you look I mean Aiden Ross I think
he's maybe 20 20 21 he's one of the
biggest streamers in the world
um like I show speed is something
similar maybe even younger maybe he's
19. uh
Kyle and all of the milk boys and maybe
getting toward the mid-20s mid late 20s
but they've got like businesses and
franchises and clothing companies and
all this stuff
I guess a lot of guys are just thinking
oh well maybe I need to take the
influencer route
and that's why they're so confused yeah
perhaps and what about is there
something else going on about some about
men's roles do you think like young guys
roles in in the world is something being
lost there
I guess so I mean I'm not massively
clear on what it was to begin with
what what do they used to be young men's
roles I don't well this is the point
with me and you were uni I was also
useless I had no idea I didn't know what
I was supposed to do but it that didn't
feel like a pressure to know what I was
supposed to do so
every generation looks back at the
generation coming after them and can't
believe how quickly they're growing up
yeah I'm pretty glad I'm not a part of
this younger generation I feel like
we are pretty sweet why
just felt like a simpler time growing up
first of all without social media I
think maybe when I get onto Facebook
that was probably one of
was at University just before University
email address when we went so it was
nice just to have my teen teenage years
without
all the social media we just weren't on
phones yeah
I had like a Sony Ericsson and Nokia
I feel like I spent a lot more time
being present
and then um
the world's a bit mad now
like really mad with all the woke stuff
and
I don't know well one of the problems
that you have is
everybody always presumes that giving
more freedom to people will allow them
to more accurately choose the precise
thing that they want right if you if
there's one pair of jeans in the store
and you go in then maybe you wanted a
different pair you only get that one if
there's a thousand pairs of jeans in the
store fantastic you can optimize your
choice precisely for the exact type of
jeans the cut the color the length the
stretch the whatever right weighs
everything the problem is
that takes the decision of the outcome
of success or failure out of the hands
of your limited choices and more into
your hands you know you see how this
would be an issue right if you choose an
ever so slightly sub-optimal pair of
genes that's your fault because there
was an optimal pair of jeans for you to
take and I think that the same thing
happens here that if the rules and
guidelines
um that people previously would have
followed
have perhaps been removed a little bit
and if expectations have been raised you
should be doing more at this age you're
able to compare yourself so on and so
forth that's a really Perfect Blend of
um
internal uncertainty and external
pressure that can cause someone to think
holy [__] like I I don't know what I'm
supposed to do with my life I don't know
all of the things previously the traits
that I would have taken pride in the uh
you know the protector provider
competent courageous Brave stands up
well under pressure doesn't give up
easily emotionally mature all of those
things that specifically men would have
relied on
that's only one step away from toxic
masculinity yeah right all of those can
very easily be well protecting why is it
that you think that women need to be
protected should not be the case that
women can be safe without the protection
of men what is it you're intending on
doing with them oh provide it you think
that women can't afford to look after
themselves you want women back in the
kitchen do you don't want them to have
careers you're like holy [__] like can
we not turn the volume of this
conversation yeah because you must have
had a lot of these conversations with
the interviews you've done do you find
do you think it's uh the dating
Market at the moment is the worst it's
ever been
it's a really good question
um I certainly think that it's the most
confusing and the outcomes seem to have
the highest rates of sexlessness that
we've ever seen so 30 of men ish around
about a third of men haven't had sex in
the last year aged 18 to 30. this stat
that just came out from Pew a couple of
weeks ago
fifty percent of men say that they're
pursuing a relationship short-term or
long term which means that 50 of men
aren't aged 18 to 30. now both me and
you and everybody that's listening that
has a penis who's been through the ages
of 18 to 30 knows what the male sex
drive feels like at that age can you
imagine what it what the world has to be
like and what your experience of life
has to be like for your sex drive to be
chopped in half essentially right
driving mad yeah but but these guys are
self-identifying as saying I'm not
bothered about a short-term or a
long-term relationship like for you to
get yourself to the stage where you've
tamped down on that sex right and
there's a talk of like reducing levels
of testosterone phthalates in the water
increasing levels of estrogen and
everything that we eat less time outside
blah blah blah like people know that
testosterone's dropped one percent a
year since 1980.
um
so that may contribute to it too but in
2019 it was 61 of guys were short-term
and long term looking for the short-term
long-term mating thing and that's
dropped 11 in four years it's like rapid
decline so I certainly do think that
what are these guys doing and they just
focusing on their own
[__]
that's a really good question I don't
know I think that a lot of guys are
retreating from The Real World monk mode
now but if they were if it was proper
monk mode where it's I'm working on my
self-development I'm building myself up
I'm
that would indicate that they're taking
a break to then come back in to
integrate into both society and dating
but I think that a lot of these guys are
just fully checked out even at younger
ages you know like under 20 like guys
that are under 20 going men going their
own way it's like dude like you haven't
had chance to not go your own way
I'm trying to think if I was 18 year old
if I was 18 now
it would be a lot harder
compared to when I was 18
harder to do what
it was a date
I think now because of social media it's
obviously way more competitive and I
just think a lot of women who are let's
say I was 18 they're 18 they're probably
not going to be looking for an 18 year
old to date they'll be looking for older
guys to date but I feel like that wasn't
as much of a thing back then absolutely
not no but the the amount of people that
you had access to would have been
limited but you know coming out the back
of this conversation I had yesterday at
this debate in Doha it was all about
masculinity masculinity being under
attack and I think that this is a
concern for women as well like a massive
concern so I found I found this really
really like interesting story about the
Batman Dark Knight Rises uh movie
premiere so it's 2012 in Aurora Colorado
and there was a shooting that happened
there the shooter was a lone man I think
he was 27 years old so he enters the
movie theater and he starts unloading
rounds just kind of at will and three
men 24 26 and 27 threw themselves on top
of their girlfriends to use their bodies
as Shields all three men died
all three women survived
if that is the kind of masculinity that
you want to get rid of in the modern
world if that's the one that is toxic
and part of a oppressive patriarchal
superstructure that's misogynistically
keeping everybody down and you want to
get rid of that
we don't live on the same Planet like
there is no world in which
that is the sort of benevolent Force for
good where somebody sacrifices
themselves for someone that they love
that you want to get rid of like how can
you tell me that that's something that's
a good way that we should get rid of
that
inbuilt
uh uh desire to protect and here's the
thing you could say that it's chivalry
or it's cultured or it's slightly
programmed
you're telling me that these guys after
bullets are flying have thought to
themselves hmm like what's the like
proper thing to do in what would Society
want me to do and from first principles
they've created a world where they go oh
yes I should throw myself on top you
know it's an instinct that's deeper and
more more inbuilt than that and I'm just
I'm really genuinely becoming concerned
about this Retreat from society that men
are suffering with and
I couldn't agree more man like I'm do
you think the the fighting back a bit
now thanks to Andrew Tate there's more
people
bringing out more masculine content
standing up for masculinity
yes I think
the best maybe not in the mainstream
media but I feel like on
social media there's more of it I would
agree uh I certainly think that Tate's
got an exaggerated view of masculinity
and I think that Shapiro hits the nail
on the head which is that Tate is almost
always right about the diagnosis but
significantly less right about the
prescription to fix it that he is able
to point out the problems but his
Solutions much of the time aren't going
to be quite as effective I think the
delivery needed work as well yeah so
there's a concept I've come up with
called the soft signal of Effectiveness
and what this means is that if you are
having a discussion with somebody that
disagrees with you or that maybe just
hasn't made their mind up
you have to realize if you make them
feel silly or foolish or ridiculous that
they're going to dig their heels into
their position you don't nobody has ever
been patronized or ridiculed into
changing their mind because it just
creates this defense to happen and this
is why like I'm nowhere near Red pilled
enough for most of the manosphere but
I'm significantly far too red pilled for
almost all of the people that are on the
Milwaukee side of things
um but I genuinely believe that that's
the most effective way to change Minds
like if you make people feel feel silly
they're gonna dig their heels in and I
think that that's one of the challenges
that that Andrew comes up against now it
Garners an awful lot of views which is
great and it is good for getting a
message out there but in terms of
changing Behavior effectively I'm not
too sure but obviously you you had how
many plays is that video they're like
six million views is that your most
played video no I'll be like this I
think it's like the third most played
right but it's like climbing up to the
top yeah and you did that kind of a
little bit before his yeah explosion so
talk me through you know we've been
talking so far about the challenges that
men face in the modern world problems of
masculinity you've spent a good bit of
time with Tate
what were your thoughts after having
spent time with him how do you think
he's contributing to the conversation on
masculinity why is he failing and
falling short
I think the problem was all the short
form content that was
getting put out there obviously it was
just like the most extreme out of
context Clips mostly from some of his
old videos
so when he when he started off he's been
doing content for a long time his older
videos are just wild like he's just
saying some mad [__] but he can do
because nobody is even watching right so
there's when not many people are
watching your videos you can get away
with saying a lot more as he became
drastically popular obviously people
going back to the old videos and were
like what the hell they were using that
content and it was just going crazy
I when I first came across him he
actually DM me this was in 2021 and
um
I went on his Instagram and I went to a
few pictures and I just thought
who is this guy like it seemed like he
was
um
trying to show off a little bit too much
and I thought it was all just a front
you know how a lot of people out here
just
trying to show hey I've got money that's
what I thought when I saw him I was like
this guy's just chatting [__] but then I
did a little bit of research and I
listened to some of the podcasts I think
the first one he went on the other two
was fresh and fit
and then that was the first time I'll
I'd actually listened to someone I was
like whoa like this guy this guy is
speaking in a way that I've never heard
anyone speak before and he's saying
things which I haven't really heard
anyone say before so I was intrigued and
I want to listen to more and I was like
actually you know what I want to meet
this guy so we came to the bike we
linked up we did the videos for just
after you come up especially to see you
I think he I mean he's always he's all
into doing business wherever he goes
but I guess maybe that was part of the
plan at that point he just wanted to
because he saw he must have seen me
probably thought oh yeah Mike seems like
a cool guy but he saw the audience how
wrong
and then he probably thinks you know
what like he was obviously on a mission
to grow get more followers so he can
push whatever he needs to push so he
probably would have seen me okay yeah
I'll do a video on Mike and then I can
help me out with my branding and
exposure obviously that works very well
but um
yeah I met him in real life and he's
he's actually
an even better guy oh I know a lot of
people don't like him but he in real
life he's like a nice guy
polite exactly funny
and um I think that's a side which a lot
of people don't see because they he
definitely just put on some kind of a
character especially in the videos which
He makes himself
and he says things and I'm just like
like why do you say that
it's like 70 of the stuff he says he's
like yeah like I strongly agree with
that and then he will go and say
something absolutely ridiculous and it's
just like why did you need to say that
because that's the 30 that people are
going to focus on yeah yeah I think
again this didn't quite come up
yesterday it came up with uh Jordan
Peterson as the example but I said
something to the effect of
um if you're not happy with the role
models that are currently being held up
for men
offer up other ones and I asked the guy
that was across from me the debater who
do you think is a good role model for
men
and he struggled a little bit uh he
struggled a lot actually it's hard to
find someone who's the full package I
think correct but I was I was able to
say well look like it's not perfect but
I would say that the kind of man that
Peterson would tell you to be your
Andrew huberman's of the world you're
Tim ferrisses of the world you're Joe
Rogan's of the world your Joker will
links like these are people that seem to
have codes of honor and ethics they do
hard things they're courageous and brave
like you know they don't get into drama
they don't get into drama I should have
just said Mike Thurston but
I it's weird that more people don't want
it more men don't want to be like those
guys
well I don't know maybe they do maybe
they do it's just that they're not
selling that kind of sexy yeah out their
lifestyle because it doesn't necessarily
resonate like it's hard it's it's hard
difficult nuanced suffering things
I mean homozy man I was spent I spent uh
Saturday with him last week in in Vegas
podcasted trained
and I went to the power slap launch
thing with him and the guys an
unbelievably slick operator is one of
the most impressive people that have
really been getting into his content
he's a terrifyingly competent human
right
but I don't even know if he owns a car I
mean they maybe have like a car but it's
like A tes like a nice Tesla right the
guy sold his business for 100 Mil he's
now doing acquisition deals for [__]
lots and lots of money so the and this
kind of maybe explains a little bit of
of the tape phenomenon which was that
his delivery was so compelling because
say what you want about what he says the
way that he says it is incredibly
interesting and it's very very very
compelling very precise speaker good
with his words you know to go
head-to-head with Piers Morgan Piers
Morgan is as hard-nosed as you're going
to get very very good in a cantankerous
debate and he Charmed Piers Morgan twice
and beat him at chess right
he's a very competent guy but he gets
like I'll be honest when I this was last
summer I was listening to a lot of his
podcasts and he was getting me fired up
to work
the stuff he says about women I just I
usually will just ignore but when he
talks about just
doing the job regardless of how you feel
just get the job done
wake up early go to the gym
and
the fact that there's just so many other
people out there that are your potential
competitors if you don't get out there
and put the work in then they're gonna
overtake you but remember that that is
David Goggins and Joker willink's
message to a t with different delivery
and with a different package that it's
being folded into so yeah I think and
this was the point that I made if you
leave a vacuum for role models and I
think the same is coming for women you
know for the girls that have been uh
left out of this conversation so far I
think that there is a
bubbling below the surface I think that
there is a concern a big concern for
role models for girls as well yeah this
is this is a this is a problem because
I'm actually trying to find some really
good female role models for the podcast
and it's quite hard to do that
out here
yeah I wonder because we were talking
about this before I I don't know because
there is a lot of successful smart women
but they don't want to raise their voice
they don't want to be
on the camera they don't think that is I
don't know this is what I'm trying to
figure out
you've reached out to them and suggested
we have reached out to a few I have our
friends
um got a big following very smart very
intelligent and they're just like
they're avoiding it and I'm like I'm
literally giving you an opportunity
to be the voice of women and to be a
role model
to all the women out there that they
need
why why are you not doing it that's very
interesting so I let me put my
evolutionary psychologist hat on for a
second
um I would say first of all maybe it's
the uh they're probably a lot more
bothered about how they look on camera
so they would probably want everything
to be perfect
and women have bad days and they'll be
like oh my hair's messed up today so
maybe I'm not gonna film or like oh I
don't like the
angle the camera is facing on my face
yeah I mean it takes a very particular
type of woman to decide to put herself
out there as a spokesperson
um so this evolutionary psychology bias
that it seems that women have
they they try and flatten hierarchies so
a bunch of studies show that if females
especially girls in school know that
their grades are going to be made public
they're going to downplay what they got
so if guys get an A if me and you were
in Union we walked out of some
accounting exam in the CSE or like
Henderson Hall or wherever the our exam
was we would walk outside let's say that
we got it was a multiple choice and we
got the results there and then and I got
an A and you got a B I'd stick it in
your face yeah but the evidence suggests
that girls will very much try and
downplay that another body count as well
perhaps I don't think those two things
are actually linked but yeah perhaps
um but the reason that it seems to be
the case with that is that
um jealousy is
a massive risk to women
they're very competitive with each other
but they're competitive in a much more
subtle and nuanced way they don't get
they're not competitive uh outwardly
right yeah they're competitive in a much
more it's more complex and you could
maybe say more devious there's certainly
much more complex social Games women's
it makes sense I feel like but what I've
noticed recently is especially out here
at least with the guys I feel like all
the guys are out here supporting each
other
and helping each other level level up
with the women are like
they're out to
they want to be the best yeah they I
mean and they're not helping each other
dude it's it's really this is the thing
and guys can say women have got it easy
they're outperforming Us in education
and employment and blah blah blah
women are having a really [__] rough
time of it like no one is no one is
flourishing at the moment there's maybe
some guys at the top and some girls at
the absolute top that are having a great
time of it on average at the moment
that's not to say that individuals can't
have like an enjoyable life but like
it's really tough for girls at the
moment okay so there is this ever
dwindling pool of guys that are eligible
for you you have more opportunities than
ever before society says that you
shouldn't become a mother you maybe want
to have a career but also like to have
the idea to have a family but if you
have a family you treated like a
second-class citizen that's been conned
by the patriarchy into becoming a
domestic prostitute like it's really not
it's really really complex for them to
if I was a woman I I really wouldn't
know what to do no no me neither and
given the fact that we spent the first
half of this conversation talking about
how difficult it is for men and I think
that
it's maybe it's at least equal in terms
of how lost the roles are for women
going forward the one difference and I
think that this is quite a big
difference and quite an important one
is that
men are still having the finger pointed
at them and being told that they're The
Architects of their own misery and also
the architect of everybody else's as
well like if there's ever a problem with
any group usually we would say okay
what's going on how can we try and
change the world or Society so that we
can help this group flourish right
there's not enough women going to
University in 1970 so we introduced
Title IX for affirmative action and it
encourages women to go now the gender
split between men and women is 15
instead of 13 when it was in 1970 but in
the other direction so there are
fewer men going to University than there
were fewer women going to University
when that title was introduced
and now it's like why why are men
falling behind can't they pull
themselves up by their bootstraps so
that is the one of the differences and
one of the support structures that women
do have that I think is lacking most of
the men which is the uh sympathy that
the wider world would typically give
them and it's because you know like men
specifically white men have had it good
for so long that maybe it's their turn
to you know be on the receiving end of
some disadvantages for a while which is
not how the world is supposed to work
it's not supposed to be that you're like
overdrawn on your
suffering balance and now it's your turn
to to take some of this I don't think
that's the way that it's supposed to
work but yeah I I really
I really think that we're going to see
over the next few years like a challenge
for women for their role models
what am I supposed to do with my life
how can I find like Pride
and fulfillment that doesn't completely
destroy like my innate biological urges
as well what's your experience been
trying to find female guests
for your show easier for me uh because
my interest in Psychology uh area which
is dominated by women has meant that at
least 50 of the episodes that I do are
with women but this is an interesting
lesson to learn there was a period a
while ago where I was big into the
productivity space I was doing a lot of
stuff around Health and Fitness
it's a both Arenas are dominated by men
and I would get criticized for the fact
that I was bringing too many men on like
why aren't there enough men as well why
aren't there enough women uh but then
since women come on people just find
something else to criticize it's like
why is everybody from why is everybody
right leaning or why is everybody
British or why is everybody white like
you're never going to be able to make
your guest list sufficiently Pure or uh
sufficiently representative to mediate
all of people's problems and the way
that you said before we started I was
like why are you bringing your guests on
and you said
anybody that I'm interested in that's
the only way that you can go it's the
only way you can't fake the interest no
correct uh something else that's changed
with you recently which I've been very
very enjoying watching happen I'm
wearing more clothes on my Instagram
pictures that's been nice for me
personally as well yes don't lie
but your relationship with alcohol Oh
yeah talk to me about your relationship
with alcohol and how it's changed yeah
so I um I pretty much barely drink
anymore
um I used to be I guess that's because
of the whole British culture
I actually drink numerous times per week
particularly when I was growing up
University then even throughout my 20s I
was very much into my fitness but at the
same time there was always at least one
extremely heavy Blowout at the weekend
and then um it just carried on like even
I think when I was when I was
the just before no 29 at the first
experiment where I went sober for six
months
and that taught me a lot because I was
put in situations where I would normally
drink and because I was doing this
challenge I wasn't allowed to drink and
I think that was the first time that I
was in situations where usually I would
be drunk and like in a relaxed State
whatever it might be but this time like
I was sober I was doing something which
I would never do and I actually realized
it wasn't that hard to do and actually
quite liked it
and I think I just
life is the short and I can't afford to
have days wasting away feeling sorry for
myself being
aggressively hungover
which at the age I'm at now it was
pretty impressive yeah yeah yeah yeah
but what what I'll do now is I will
I will still drink but it usually tends
to be when I have done
achieved something or I've got the job
done and
I can celebrate it's like okay you've
achieved this let's go out let's
celebrate have a drink if you want to
have a drink
once that's over then it's back to the
Grind again what else have you learned
from your time going sober obviously the
reason for doing it is that you don't
want to waste your days so much but what
else have you learned I actually really
enjoy my reality being sober
um
I actually don't really like the feeling
of being drunk anymore
I think now I'm at a point where I feel
like I'm very much in control I like
that I really like the person who I am
now when I'm sober I can I'm extremely a
lot more confident now I can have
conversations with anyone I can charm
people I can you know have a laugh I can
have a dance I can do it whatever I need
to do but I can do it sober and there's
actually no real need for me to drink
and when I do drink I realize actually
I start to get a little bit sloppy with
my words I say things which I wouldn't
normally say
might potentially regret and then
there's parts of the night or
conversation which I won't remember and
then I wake up feeling like absolute
trash
spend a lot of money as well out here on
alcohol which is usually just not wise
so it's uh
when I compare the positives to the
negatives there's actually very few
positives yeah
so this I mean you know this is
something I don't know I'm thinking now
like so why did I drink that's the
question I had on the tip of my tongue
like you've you've laid out this balance
sheet of positives and negatives
why did either of us and this is both of
our upbringings right you know our
formative years in Newcastle and then
both of us stuck about once we finished
our degrees
going out drinking trabs
you know you can get absolutely
annihilated for like 10 pounds correct
yeah so again for the people that don't
know when we were at Uni could have got
three travel vodka mixers for a fiver
and you would usually get a free Jager
bomb with each of them so that's nine
shots of vodka plus three shots of
Jaeger for a fiver and the way that it
would work is you couldn't carry all of
them back you would have to pour all of
the Jaegers in together drink that drink
one of the trebs and then carry two back
um
so what I'm thinking is why is it
that
we ever saw it as
something that not only we would do we
would willingly do we would repeatedly
do two nights a week throughout all of
uni
why I think
from thinking back when I was at
University I actually don't now that I
recall I don't know anybody that didn't
drink I feel like every single person
drank yup and if there was anyone that
didn't drink they were just
they will wait you wouldn't hang out
with them but they weren't a part of the
social group yeah they weren't part of
the Social Circle
um I definitely remember drinking a lot
just feel more comfortable to reduce the
anxiety me too
um
yeah because especially when you're
having you're in uh a club the music's
really loud there's lights everywhere
there's people everywhere talking it's
really overwhelming
so the alcohol would numb that and then
you would feel more comfortable just to
interject that think about the modern
world
but this 2023 version of the world
someone would say that if that was a
challenge that you were coming up
against that that's because you're like
a blue pill beater simp guy who hasn't
worked on his masculine Essence and
stuff and I think that just to bring it
back to what we spoke about earlier on
about like why young guys struggling
specifically now
this expectation again that you should
have your [__] together you go really I
didn't yeah I didn't I absolutely drank
so I had confidence to speak to girls I
remember I used to have this I had this
uh like pink polo shirt and pair of
jeans and one night I pulled because
like and I was adamant that it was
because of this particular outfit I'm
like oh that's like that's the one
and I was so drunk that I could barely
remember what had happened during the
night and you think
what like what how
that's that's compensating for the fact
that it's
just a really highly stimulating pretty
anxiety-inducing environment
I think it it would probably make more
sense just to not go out
but that was that was like the biggest
part of university was going out
particularly Newcastle correct that was
like the reason why I choose I chose
that's correct yeah so
yeah I don't know I guess at that age
you really don't have much
responsibility like I think back to
University
I mean I just
he obviously needs to get the bare
minimum done you had to do a bit of
studying you didn't have a job you just
living off the student loan you just
haven't because you laugh yeah you might
so if you did wake up hungover then
didn't really spend the spend the day
watching the Rugby World Cup or whatever
was going on the Six Nations or some
other thing or movies in the in the
common room and then get back to it yeah
I am
um it's like I again I get that but I
think
the number of people that drink the
number of young people that are choosing
to go low and know alcohol Lifestyles
massively increasing yeah I'd love to
say that this is Downstream from a trend
that I kicked off but I think it's
bigger than that and
I do I I can't work out what's going on
there I wonder whether
I think it's more it's just accepted now
I think it was really not acceptable
back in the day unacceptable to not
drink yeah unacceptable whereas now it's
like okay yeah fair enough
maybe that I think there's a lot more
informative content out there which is
showing just how bad alcohol is like
humans than the his video about alcohol
listen to that and you're like I wanna
drink again yeah it's terrible
it's really really I think more people
are waking up to the negative side
effects of drinking alcohol
um
but it's still
there's still a lot of people drinking I
still have a lot of friends who are
drinking yeah but I just don't give a
[__] if I'm gonna offend their feelings
I wonder whether part of it
comes to choosing first off choosing the
kind of events that you go to and then
secondly that that growing in confidence
because you're right if you're in a
banging loud student nightclub with 1500
sweaty freshers and The Killers Mr
Brightside playing at ear bleeding
levels which is like beards spill on
your face correct you're that's not the
place for you to what advantage do you
have in being able to have a better
conversation now you almost need to
drink to be able to cope with the
environment that you're in to be able to
make it good and this is the thing that
I've been saying for like seven years
like if you need to drink in order to be
able to enjoy your night out you're
choosing the wrong nights out like what
you're saying is that the experience
that you're going on is so bad that you
have to anesthetize yourself you have to
numb yourself to the experience
it's like saying I'm going to go and do
this push I'm gonna go stick needles
through the skin on the back of my hand
but I'll take some painkillers it
doesn't hurt so much yeah hang on a
second as you grow up you start to do
different sorts of events you'll go for
dinner more you'll go to quieter venues
you'll go to somewhere where there's
live music where you can have a
conversation and that is that sort of
enjoyment is facilitated more by being
sober uh so I wonder whether it's a
byproduct of
of the kind of events that young people
typically attend I wonder whether Darren
my business partner is still doing all
the voodoo in the UK I wonder whether he
needs to I know do coffee and cocktail
hour at five o'clock in the afternoon or
something I don't know I think that's as
well when you're in an environment where
everybody else is drunk like that is
that's full on when you're sober and
you're just looking at people yeah
it's heavy like I I feel like if I'm in
an environment where everybody's drunk
I almost need to be drunk just to deal
with it tolerate it correct yeah
looking forward now you've got you're
doing business stuff you've got clothing
you've got app
you're still growing your platforms
as a a guy that from the outside looks
like he's accomplished a lot of things
and is living an enjoyable life in a
desirable City I actually have no room
yeah spend it all on this apartment
spend it all on this very expensive
apartment
um what are you are you accumulating
skills at the moment are you developing
yourself are there certain things that
you've set yourself with regards to
goals I think the uh the podcasting has
massively improved my ability to have a
conversation and even only 13 episodes
yeah I feel like I'm I'm learning a hell
of a lot which is which is good
but I'm doing the podcast more just to
help with growing the brand and
particularly the networking
because being in Dubai there's always so
many people coming in and out and
whenever I do meet up with someone who
is quite interesting and having a really
amazing conversation I'm like should
have recorded that yeah like this
this needs to be out there and it's not
the right type like you can't do it
wouldn't work in a vlog because a vlog
you chop things up and it's like you
would only take five minutes of it so
that was one reason and another one is
um
it gives you
it opens doors for meeting very
interesting people or people who I
respect and want to meet thank you
because
I
you know somebody who say for example
who's been very successful or the
killing it making loads of money I maybe
don't really have much to offer them
maybe I could help them get in shape but
that's not a quick fix and it's not
something I particularly want to do I
don't want to be a personal trainer for
celebrities
but when you have an audience and you
have a platform all of a sudden you
become uh potentially a good asset to
them because if they're releasing a book
or they want to spread a message or they
want to increase their own
following then coming onto the podcast
is going to be exactly what they want
so
that's it's like a strategic thing but
I'm also learning a lot at the same time
is there anything else is there anything
else that you're thinking at the moment
is a an area of your life that needs
optimizing yeah
um
monetizing the following because uh both
yeah so
I think um
I've been good uh building a brand and
growing a following but I'm actually
quite [__] at selling things
so and it's it's weird because I guess I
never really learned much about it like
even though I went to school and went to
University you don't get taught how to
sell at school how to Market University
I did economics and business management
but still it was like so heavy on the
theory the maths the equations I was
like I thought I was going to learn how
to run a business here but I'm not
learning any of that so those skills are
never really developed and obviously I
got straight into personal training so I
mastered the art of building muscle
losing body body fat how to communicate
with people my presentation skills
but no
marketing or it's not commercializing
stuff this is something that I told I
like lament about this all the time just
how much is getting left on the table
you know we both have friends who will
have significantly uh easier weeks with
less work with smaller followings with
less impact adding less value
making so much more money and it's not
even necessarily about the money I don't
think that either of us are like you
know needing more materialism in our
lives but there's just a sense of well
I'm leaving a lot on the table here and
yeah that's because I'm not I'm not
motivated by money obviously you need it
but once you reach a certain amount
you don't really need more unless you
want what you do get a slightly nicer
apart it would be another 10 floors up
or something you know it's unless you
want to start investing and buying
property or you want to build another
business then okay yeah but that's the
one thing about Dubai is I've
particularly in the past year I remember
I think it was like
maybe I got back from traveling last
summer and my goal was look I just want
to build my network I just want to meet
people I want to meet I want to surround
myself with successful people who are
doing very well
and I've met a lot of interesting people
in fact the majority of people I'm
hanging out with now have nothing to do
with Fitness they're just extremely
successful in their own
field
and it's crazy to
like you said they might have 10 000
followers 20 000 followers on Instagram
crushing it and they're making so much
money I'm like whoa yeah like how are
you doing that yeah
and they tell me like oh yeah the sales
funnel I'm like
yeah I I mean this is this is something
that will be very interesting to see
how the next couple of years develops
because I'm very conscious of not like
selling out yeah I've been the same I
don't
know anyone watches my content I very
rarely push things onto my followers
yeah yeah and I think that in the long
term that's the right way to go about
things right because your your
reputation is something that you can't
buy back if you do sell your integrity
there is no refund policy on that and
whatever it is it takes a a lifetime to
build trust and it's like this is Logan
Paul like he's just so I mean he's a
really good example or a very
interesting one because it seems like
him and his brother can just steamroll
through issues you know the coffee Zella
thing was really damning it was two part
of three-part series that kind of broke
down all of this stuff that Logan was
doing with his nfts and then coffee goes
on Rogan and Rogan asks him what's the
biggest thing and then they they pull
that and they put that on a clip on
Rogan's 20 million person YouTube
channel which gives it another lease of
life and meanwhile Logan Paul is doing
WWE and he's making money on Prime and
he's got all of these businesses I don't
know what it is and I would love for
someone to explain it to me those guys
both Logan and Jake have an uncanny
ability to just keep moving through
obstacles yeah bad things happen and it
just doesn't phase them I remember after
this Tommy Fury Jake Paul fight
there was a video that he uploaded it
might even be in the first story of the
next day on his Instagram and it was him
going looking at the camera and being
happy and then looking down and putting
his head in his hands as if he was sad
and the caption below was when you lost
the fight but made 30 mil
you can't [__] knock it you can't
knock that
um so there's something happening with
them and I really want to try and
deconstruct
what's going on well I think the
fighting thing was very good because you
can't
you've always got to respect someone
who's gonna step into the ring goodbye
like you
even have not done that but why is Logan
able to continue plowing through
these challenges and accusations of of
nft [__] and stuff yeah it's weird
because it's almost like
maybe because he's been through it
before and he knows yeah you're gonna be
the most hated man on the planet for a
couple of days or weeks and then people
forget about it and then it's just back
to business as usual
so he's personally capable of dealing
with it but even that like you know
someone could be personally capable and
their reputation could be damaged that
should be independent what happens to
the right do you think let's say for
example everything that's happened with
liver King do you think his reputation
is that because I went on his Instagram
the other day and he's still getting
loads of likes and comments and Views
and I'm like why are people still
watching unbelievable I don't know like
how how is this house
he was there just with a big plate of
testicles
and I just thought
wow nothing's changed still doing his
thing
what do you think about living King
that's interesting very interesting guy
I don't know I I think it was it was he
did so many interviews where he was
literally asked whether or not it was
natural and he just says like so almost
convincing he's like no I've not taken
anything
I don't feel like that was necessary
I feel like if you just said yeah I was
I want a bit of this I want a bit of
that people would have been like oh yeah
okay because most people a lot of people
in Industry at the moment are taking
stuff anyway that we've undermined his
ancestral message that's right heavily
yeah I guess so yeah because he was
push natural thing yeah
apart from those steroids well I think
that yeah
the fact that he was doing that and he'd
already sent that email to Derek like
he's playing with fire
like this
I so the liver King thing is kind of
fascinating to look at now as a
post-mortem and maybe it is similar to
Logan Paul I've got this idea that I've
been playing with for a little while to
do with uh how seduced by success the
world is and uh do you remember Billy
McFarland the guy that did fire Festival
oh yeah yeah so uh again for the people
that don't know this Festival five
Festival was supposed to be it was run
on Pablo Escobar's Island and Kendall
Jenner was part of the promotion
campaign for it and it was going to be
this Elite super high class music
festival and Blink 182 we're going to
play and it's this amazing Headliners
and the whole thing turned out to be a
car crash and basically people nearly
died there was no water there was no
nothing
but had Billy McFarland managed to pull
off even uh
remotely acceptable event
he would have been hailed as a marketing
genius as opposed to a charlatan con man
and the only difference between
how people perceived him
was the success of the event that didn't
change the ethics of how he got there in
terms of his marketing practices how
he'd raised money which was done like
incredibly unethically lying to people
about where the money was going and
flying back and forth to and from New
York and all of this sort of stuff
and what that made me realize is
for as long as you're successful
people will put up with pretty much
anything
because they are so concerned about
being in the trickle-down cast off
your success they want to bask in the
reflective glow of whatever it is that
you do so much that they're prepared to
forgive pretty much any indiscretion and
this is what will be interesting to see
what happens with Tate when he
inevitably comes back into the public
Limelight perhaps from a witness box
perhaps from behind bars or perhaps if
he gets released back out into the real
world
because
is it going to be the case
that he is continuing to grow and have
this platform
there has to be it's almost like a
balance like a seesaw right on one side
you have the amount of success that
people want to be associated with and on
the other side you have the laundry list
of bad things that are happening Logan
Paul like suicide forest nft thing
liver King that like the steroids and
this and maybe there's another Scandal
that comes whatever and it feels to me
like it's a balancing act between the
two
Billy McFarland you know Billy McFarland
seesaw tip too far in the other
direction right he didn't have enough
success to hold up the amount of
unethical business practices that he was
going through and
that thing that I learned watching fire
Festival like if you're successful
people will forgive
an awful lot of indiscretions
I think that's probably quite true yeah
[__]
what's happening next what are you
working on next
uh doing a mastermind
uh next weekend certain person yes we've
got 12 people coming to spend the
weekend with me what are they learning
coaching online coaching business so
it's a combination of
they they want to see Dubai
they want to get trained by me they want
to learn about how to build a brand how
to build social media you also want to
meet the people I know so I'll introduce
them to my network so I've got a whole
host of events and activities planned
over the Friday Saturday and Sunday I
think the Highlight will be a big yacht
which I've rented out on this Saturday
afternoon so I came on the wrong weekend
yeah so I'm gonna invite literally
everybody who I know who is worth
knowing and just put everybody together
on a nice yacht so it'll be an
opportunity for everyone to just chat
that's really cool there's a number of
um like Builder events in Austin people
that are building [__] creators Founders
startups CEOs writers podcasters YouTube
Etc
and Devin Levesque is doing something
cool he's got a ranch out in Texas he
just followed me yeah he followed me
this week he seems like a cool guy yeah
he's he's on it he's uh I think he's
he's so he's converted a barn and it's
like a HQ for him throwing these events
you've got ice baths everywhere like
it's it's cool he's like building a
community
I think that's maybe one thing that I've
been lacking uh I could definitely do
with improving
the the community which I have
it could definitely be strengthened
that's you're not the first person to
tell me that in Dubai yeah I think it's
a place that because of the way not
there's a number of reasons one of them
geographically doesn't really lend
itself to that it does not
the
let's just go to a local coffee garden
and and meet up with 20 of our friends
and we can just chat and anybody can
invite anybody that's very common in
Austin once a week once every two weeks
there must be one of these events one of
them is called based in Austin dude 150
people would turn up and just just
because and people would bring cases of
water people would bring cases of
sparkling water and like one guy would
go and get tacos and
and then you just talk and then someone
would say uh I'm actually going to go
and give a talk over there about what
I've learned to do with decentralized
whatever or my new sub stack strategy or
whatever people go and listen to some
dude just go and talk so that there
needs to be more of that because I think
uh
a lot of
a lot of guys who I've spoken to they
have a hard time networking and meeting
people maybe guys that are older than
them or like-minded people who are just
all they want to do is just grow they
want to succeed they want to build and
it can be very hard particularly if you
come to it like I'd imagine there's a
hell of a lot of people that come to
Dubai but they don't know anyone yeah
and they're like Mike well
how do you get yourself to these events
luckily for me because obviously I've
been here for a while I have a network
and I've established myself here so I
get invited to a lot of these things but
if you're a nobody that can be quite
difficult
so if there is more of these events
where pretty much anybody can attend to
like it's in my opinion it's
life-changing because you may meet some
friends which you'll have the rest you
like we might have some conversations
that will literally cause you to go on a
completely different path
you know I I just from
having a a dinner with a group of
friends some people who I didn't know uh
some who I did they introduced me to one
guy he was the one actually gave me the
idea of doing a mastermind and I was
like
I actually never really thought about
doing that but then it made sense
because this there's so many people
every day that message me saying hey
Mike I'm in Dubai can I meet you or can
I train with you can I do this can I do
that
so now this is obviously going to be a
tester it's a small scale thing it's
only 12 people but if this goes well and
I enjoy it then maybe I could do it
again in the future
on a larger scale well this speaks to
again one of the challenges both young
guys and younger and older people as
well perhaps it even gets worse as you
get older that making friends having a
community you know having a support
group uh I I feel very very fortunate
that Austin is just
it's like overpowered when it comes to
community and socializing it's insane
I've never ever ever been anywhere that
is so hypersocial and it's dinners it's
dinners and everything's finished by 8
30 PM because everyone's got to get up
in the morning to go and do stuff right
or they've got to get back to look after
the dog so it's not hedonistic it never
gets a
maybe I don't get invited but it never
gets out of control I'm pretty sure
and that has been so for me really
nourishing fulfilling and it's filled a
massive hole that I thought I needed
um and yeah because because all my my
really close friends like oh Party Boys
yeah and I can't I mean obviously I'll
link up with them every now and then and
you know
unsustainable regular friendships
unsustainable you're gonna kill me
Mike I appreciate the [__] out of you
man it's very very cool to have watched
what you've done over the last whatever
15 16 years since we've been mates and
uh I'm looking forward to seeing how the
podcast continues to grow for people
that are listening they want to check
out the stuff that you do where should
they go so just search for Mike Thurston
on any platform my website thirst
official pick up a pair of sexy shorts
if you want to and then uh podcast
channel is first things first
I appreciate you thanks man
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign